One argument you might make against undecidability and the importance of saying
whether a problem is undecidable, is that every computer is actually finite.
It has a finite amount of state.
It can run for a finite length of time.
Therefore we can determine whether a program halts or not simply by letting it run
either until it terminates or it arrives at a state where it has already been.
By state I mean the memory in the computer is exactly the same,
and we are executing the same line of code as we were the previous time around.
Because if both of those things are true we are going to loop back around again
and have the same memory and line of code executing,
and again, and again.
Then we'll know if it will terminate or not.
One of the problems with this is that today's computers have a whole lot of memory.
So why don't we try it with something a little bit smaller?
Let's try it with a smaller computer.
A computer that only has a single kilobyte of total memory.
This is a ridiculously small amount of memory for this day and age.
It's really kind of a joke. You can't even fit the Udacity logo in this amount of memory.
Now remember, a kilobyte is a 1,000 bytes, and a byte has 8 bits in it,
which can each be set to either 0 or 1.
Let's say that this computer can take 10 billion steps in a single second.
What I'd like to know is if we did this, and we wanted to know if a program that we were
running on this computer would terminate, how many years could it potentially take us
to decide if our given program terminates?
I'd like your answer in the exponent for 10 to the---however many numbers of years.
If you'd like a little bit of a hint, the age of the universe is estimated at about 14 billion
or 10 to the 10th years.
Your answer should be substantially larger than that.
Go ahead and enter the exponent in here.